翻訳: Keiko Ishigami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんこんにちは
土井隆雄です
私はこの4月1日に
京都大学宇宙ユニットに着任しました
私は 京都大学に来る前
約20年にわたって
日本の有人宇宙活動の
前線で働いていました
今日は この私の経験を
皆さんにお伝えしながら
有人宇宙活動「人が宇宙へ行く」
ということはどういうことなのか
一緒に考えたいと思います
どうぞよろしくお願いします
日本の有人宇宙活動は
1985年に始まりました
３人の宇宙飛行士が選ばれました
毛利さん 向井さん そして私です
毛利さんは1992年に
アメリカのスペースシャトル
「コロンビア号」に乗って
宇宙実験をしました
1985年以後 大体２年に１度位の割合で
日本人の宇宙活動が始まりました
それは 2008年まで続きます
この1985年から
2008年までのこの期間を
「有人宇宙活動の第１期」
と呼んでいます
この期間では
１つのミッションごとに
新しい有人宇宙技術を得ようという
そういう努力がされてきました
そして2008年に至ります
2008年に何が起こったかというと
日本の国際宇宙ステーション
「きぼう」モジュールが宇宙に行きました
25年に及ぶ努力の成果です
この2008年以後を
私達は「日本の有人宇宙活動の第２期」
と呼んでいます
ですから 今私達のいるこの時は
日本の有人宇宙活動の
第２期にあたっています
この第２期を
もう少し詳しく見てみましょう
まず 2008年ですけども
私のフライトで「きぼう」の
１番目のモジュールが宇宙に行きました
そのあと 星出さん 若田さんと続いて
３つのモジュールが宇宙に行って
「きぼう」のモジュールが完成されました
で 若田さん以後
日本の宇宙飛行士による
長期滞在が始まりました
特に2010年 野口さんのフライトの時に
山崎さんが宇宙に行きました
ちょうどこの時 ですから
宇宙には２人の日本人が
いたことになります
新しい宇宙飛行士のグループの
皆さんも飛び始めています
昨年 油井亀美也さんが
宇宙ステーションに滞在しました
また 大西さんは 7月から現在まで
宇宙ステーションに滞在しています
彼は 今週ですね
地球に戻ってくることになっています
来年 金井さんが
宇宙ステーションに飛ぶ予定です
日本の宇宙ステーション活動は
この予定だと 2024年まで
続くことになっています
ここで１つ 問題があります
問題は 2025年以降の
日本の有人宇宙活動計画が
できていないことです
2025年まで
約８年とちょっとしかないです
普通 有人宇宙活動というのは
10年 15年かかります
そういう意味で
もう日本は今この時に
2025年以降の有人宇宙活動計画を
作る必要がありますが
まだそれができていません
ここでちょっと 私の宇宙ミッションを
皆さんに紹介したいと思います
スペースシャトル
「エンデバー号」に乗って
2008年3月11日 宇宙に行きました
日本の宇宙ステーション
「きぼう」の第一便です
これはちょうど
真夜中の打ち上げでしたので
ちょうど打ち上げの写真は
こんな感じになります
スペースシャトル「エンデバー号」
全重量が2,000トンあります
ですから 大体 小型車2,000台分の
重さのものが
宇宙に飛んでいくというわけです
すごい 世界最高性能の
７人乗りのロケットでした
宇宙まで8分30秒で到達してしまいます
8分30秒と言うと
非常に短く感じられますが
その最終速度は
秒速８kmまで上がります
秒速８kmというと
１分間に500km行きますから
今 ちょうど皆さんのいる京都を発って
１分後には東京を超えて
茨城県の辺りまで行ってしまうという
そういう凄いスピードまで到達します
このミッションのために
私達は ２年間の訓練をしました
ここに写っているのが 私の仲間達です
この２年間の訓練期間中
もちろんスペースシャトルを
使えるようになること
宇宙ステーションの各機器を
そういう宇宙での仕事について
色んな訓練をしましたが
私にとって１つ
とても大事だったことがあります
それは チームワークを作ることです
宇宙へは 独りでは行けません
宇宙という真空無重力環境
沢山の人達が一丸となって働いて
初めて実現できます
このチームワークは
自分が自分のメンバーを信じられるか
自分の命を預けられるか
また 自分の仲間達が
自分を信じてくれるか
命を預けてくれるか
そういう意味で
自分の命を預けることができる
チームワークを作るということが
宇宙ミッションには必要です
この２年間を通して
この７人 また地上でサポートしてくれる
人々とのチームワークが上手く作れて
それが今 自分にとって
本当に大きな財産になっています
これが 私たちが行った
宇宙ステーションです
これは 2011年に完成した時の写真です
日本の実験棟「きぼう」のモジュールが
その先端に付いています
宇宙ステーションは
地上から400kmの高度を飛んでいます
この高度を秒速８kmで周っています
そうすると何が起こるかというと
90分で地球の周りを１周します
ですから45分ごとに 昼と夜が来ます
宇宙というのはそういう不思議な世界です
大きさは ちょうどこの左端から右端まで
110mあります
太陽電池パネルが ４組付いています
この太陽電池パネルの長さは
70mありますから
この全体の大きさというのは
ちょうどサッカー場１個の大きさにあたります
重量は約420トン
人間が宇宙で作った
世界最大の構造物です
今現在 ６人の宇宙飛行士が常時滞在して
宇宙空間で地球を観測したり
宇宙の観測をしたり
また新しい科学技術の発見を目指して
色々な実験をしています
宇宙 無重力の世界です
こんな仲間との集合写真が簡単に撮れます
無重力の世界
全てのものが浮いている世界
椅子も机もない世界です
1961年に ガガーリンが
初めて宇宙に行きました
その時私達は色んな疑問を持っていました
宇宙で人間は
生きていくことができるのか？
水を飲むことができるのか？
食べ物を食べることができるのか？
寝ることができるのか？
きちんと考えることができるのか？
仕事が出来るのか？
色んな疑問を持っていました
今 私達は全ての疑問に答えることができます
宇宙で人間は 地上と同じように
生活し仕事をすることができます
水を飲むことも食べることも
地上と同じように何の努力もなく
普通にすることができます
よく眠ることができます
ものを考えることができます
仕事もできます
何でも自由に地上と同じように
私たちは宇宙で活動することができます
この人間の身体は
地上で生まれて育って進化して
この地上の１Gの世界しか
知らないこの身体が
宇宙の無重力状態でも
きちんと働くことができるように作られている
これは本当に素晴らしいことだと思います
その結果として私達は宇宙へ展開する力を
持っていることになります
この有人宇宙活動
私がこの京都大学に来た時に
「では 京都大学で自分は一体何が
できるだろうか？」と自分に質問しました
その答えがこれです
「有人宇宙活動を担う
高い専門性を持つ次世代人材の育成」を
してやろうと思いました
有人宇宙活動はまた
新しいことへチャレンジする
挑戦していく活動でもあります
ですから 「高い専門性を持つ」
という代わりに
「新しいことにチャレンジしていく
次世代人材の育成」と
言い換えてもいいかと思います
有人宇宙活動は
３つの特徴を持っています
１つは 最先端科学技術を使うということ
人が無重力 真空環境に行くためには
本当に今使える最先端の科学技術が必要です
また人が行くということから
人文社会的連携も必要になります
もちろん人が命を懸けて
新しい挑戦をするわけですから
国民の関心が高いです
このような有人宇宙活動を引っ張っていく
若い人達が多くなれば
もちろん有人宇宙活動が活性化します
それはまた 宇宙開発の利用の拡大に繋がり
宇宙産業が拡大してきます
宇宙産業はまた
それを地上の色々な暮らしや活動に
広げることによって
社会的効果としては 社会全体で
新しい産業が生まれると言って良いと思います
もう少しすると
宇宙から新しい産業革命が起こると
私は信じています
その結果としてもちろん
国民の高い関心が 更に高くなって
そうするとこの正のループが起こるとすると
宇宙活動がますます盛んになっていく
それを目指したいと思いました
ところが１つ 問題があります
それは先ほど言った
日本は2025年以降 有人宇宙活動の計画を
持っていないということです
それは何かと言うと
宇宙ステーション活動が
この下向きの矢印に相当しています
それがまだこの上向きの矢印に
変換してないですね
それはなぜかと考えた時に
やはり
有人宇宙活動を志す
若い人材が育っていない
もう１つ 原因があると思いました
それは宇宙活動
「人が宇宙に行く」ということを語るべき
学問が存在してないということですね
そこで私はここに来て
「有人宇宙学を作ろう」と
皆さんに今 働きかけている最中です
有人宇宙学は 人間と宇宙を繋ぐ学問です
今までもちろん
人間と宇宙を繋ぐ学問というのは
作られてきました
ちょうど皆さんから見て
この右側に載っているところですね
宇宙工学や宇宙のための建築学
心理学 また宇宙科学 地球科学
そういう学問が作られてきていました
理工学を中心とした学問が作られてきました
人が宇宙に行くということによって
もちろん 社会学とか経済学とか
そういう人文社会科学系の学問が
ちょっとだけ 使われるように
なっていますが
これを見ると どうも学問というには
底が浅い 奥行きがない
これだとやはり人々に訴える力がない
何か足りないものがある
人間と宇宙を繋ぐ間に
何かひとつ欠けている
そう感じました
それで色々考えました
それで見つけたのがこれです
時間を入れてやろうと思いました
そうすると何ができるかというと
人間 宇宙 時間を繋ぐこの三角形ができます
三角形を支えている学問を全部融合して
有人宇宙学を作ろうと考えました
例えば 宇宙と時間を結ぶ矢印は
科学や物理学 天文学 数学があります
人間や時間を結ぶ矢印には
歴史学から始まって
生理学 医学まであります
そういう人間が今まで作ってきた
ほとんどあらゆる学問というのが
この有人宇宙学に含まれる
ということになります
また ここに挙げている学問というのは
地球上で 人類が地上で生きていくために
作った学問です
これは宇宙では役に立たない
宇宙で人間が展開するためには
視点を宇宙に上げて
宇宙で使える学問にしないといけない
ですから私達はこういう総ての学問を
宇宙レベルに引っ張り上げよう
という努力を始めたところです
この有人宇宙学
私たちの現実の世界にあててみたのが
このスライドです
宇宙と時間 それは何を意味するか？
宇宙の進化ですね
ビッグバンから始まって
銀河系ができ 惑星系ができた宇宙の進化
100億年を語る学問分野です
それから 人間と時間は２つあります
まず生命の進化
海で生命が生まれて陸に上がり
それから今 宇宙へ行こうとしている
この生命の進化を語る時間
１億年の時間です
それから人間が知恵をもって
村を作り 町を作って 都市を作る
約１万年に及ぶ時間スケール
これも私達の有人宇宙学に入ってきます
この４つの分野がまとまって
人間が宇宙へ行くための学問が
作れるのではないかと考えました
そのために最近
この４つの分野を研究する
研究班を作りました
研究班１は宇宙の進化
宇宙を知る研究班
研究班２は生命の進化
宇宙を生きることを知る研究班
それから研究班３は
文明の進化 宇宙で考える研究班
それから宇宙でものを作る研究班４
宇宙で[もの]を作る研究班４です
この活動は 今まだ始まったばかりです
ここに来られている皆さん
もし興味があるならば
どうぞ有人宇宙学の創出に
参加してください
私の今までの宇宙体験を考えると
２つ印象に残ります
１つは宇宙から見る
地球の素晴らしさです
しかし宇宙から見ると
同時に 地球が１つの惑星である
ということが分かります
それは有限な世界です
地球上の全ての生命が
この一つの世界にしか存在していない
この素晴らしい地球を
これからも守っていかなければいけないと
強く感じました
２つ目は 人間は素晴らしい力を持つ
ということです
この巨大な構造物を
宇宙に作ることができた人間
協力すれば何でもできると感じました
今人類文明というのは
地球から宇宙へ展開しようとしています
それも 私達人間が力を合わせれば
可能であると思います
最後に 私の大好きな言葉を
皆さんに贈ります
「宇宙を目指せ」
皆さん 今日はどうも
ありがとうございました
(拍手)